uh julian treasure welcome to stockholm
um
you're you're you're a sound expert and
you're also the author of the book sound
business yes um
and first of all is my sound level okay
now perfect it's perfect thank you
you're a pro
thank you uh
the sounds of modern life
uh
they are they are very different from
from what they used to be before uh
what are the actual effects of sound
sound affects us in four ways and the
first of those is physiological
so i just gave you a little shot of
cortisol which is your fight flight
hormone sudden sounds are doing that to
us all the time in city life if you
imagine surf that has the opposition
just by clapping well that was the sound
and the shock
whenever if a bus backfires behind you
you get the same effect
surf on the other hand slows you down
it's got roughly the same frequency as a
sleeping human's breathing so we find it
very restful
second way is psychological so you could
play a piece of music i'm sure that
would make you feel happy or one that
would make you feel sad we're very
familiar with that
not just music the natural sounds like
birdsong for example can change mood
we've learned over hundreds of thousands
of years that when the birds are singing
things are safe so birdsong tends to
make most people feel secure at a very
deep level
third way is cognitive
so you can't understand two people
talking at once you know that feeling in
it if you're in a party and two people
are talking at the same time it's
overload
in fact 1.6 people is all you can
understand
so if you're in a busy office and
there's people talking around you that
has a devastating effect actually people
in open plan offices that are noisy are
roughly one-third as productive as
people in quiet rooms so that's a
shocking statistic so with all these
sounds around us all the time are we
going slightly crazy or is it
uh for example 25 of europe's population
are having their sleep disrupted by
noise that's well above the world health
organization
recommended limits and that that leads
to all sorts of problems it leads to
stress it leads to depression it leads
to even violence
neighbor noise is a big problem and it
accounts for a lot of deaths now where
people get so angry
they kill people the noise made me do it
absolutely there's a famous case of a
fireman in new york who killed a load of
people because he just couldn't stand
the noise anymore if you if you can
explain how our hearing works how would
you explain that sure well it's quite
simple there's three stages the first
stage is physical
so sound hits your eardrums it actually
touches you this is what i love sound
sound is actually touching you all the
time it's touching your eardrums
and the smallest sound you can hear
moves your eardrum just three atomic
diameters that's incredible the loudest
sound you can tolerate is a trillion
times more powerful than that what would
that be uh well something like standing
next to a jet engine
that would rupture your eardrums
do we do we all listen in the same way
no and in fact there are listening
positions it's a tragedy you know
hearing is one thing we all hear
some better than others
listening is a skill
and it's a skill that we're not taught
at school
which to me is crazy you know it's a
very important thing any salesman will
tell you listening is just as important
as talking in any conversation
so you can have listening positions
i'll give you a couple of examples a
typical listening position for men for
you and me would be reductive like
listening for
so you've got a problem i give you a
solution thanks end of conversation on
we go to the next thing you know that's
how men listen for a point
whereas women typically listen
expansively so they'll listen
just to listen and to be with and to
empathize
so if any men are watching this if they
just explore that expansive listening
you know when she comes home and says
i've had this problem she doesn't want
to hear have a bath you'll be fine
she wants to hear you poor thing
and just be with
it's a different form of listening it's
great to explore listening positions
very powerful
which which are the sounds that we
dislike the most the number one sound
that we dislike is babies crying really
yeah really because we're genetically
programmed to do something about that
you know it it means you you should do
something so sitting on a plane for
eight hours next to a crying baby is
pretty stressful
number two uh is the sound of somebody
being sick
number three is scraping like nails on
blackboard or
yeah or you know steel legs on a
terracotta floor or something like that
not nice
is it like the the sound of civilization
you you mentioned the sound of the city
is is that really also uh something that
we it's not good for us like people in
mumbai are they less happy than people
in louisville in norway northern norway
where it's totally quiet
generally there's not enough silence in
our world i mean silence is a little bit
like a sorbet in a meal you know it
cleans your palate any musician will
tell you after a while in the studio uh
that your ears go you can't you can't do
it anymore you have to go and get some
peace to reset and silence is very
important for that reason in fact the
elizabethans described conversation as
decorated silence and i think that's a
beautiful phrase
so silence is important noise doesn't
necessarily cause harm to us but
uncontrolled noise something i can't
turn off that's going all the time is
going to make me ill eventually
how is this in the in the rock and roll
business i mean how are your ears today
uh after pretty messed up actually yeah
because uh
actually you're dealing with very loud
noises on stage especially when you're
saying play punk rock and
you're hell-bent on being the loudest
man on earth and of course that that
really messes up your your eardrums
physically
for some hours you know i have tinnitus
now which only came on this last year
unfortunately since i've been doing this
job i've had great hearing but i'm a
drummer so i'm at the bottom you're a
drummer
oh i'm really sorry about it
it was her it wasn't me
i'm married to a beautiful woman so i'm
fine thank you very much but but um
years of playing the drums it's like
you're hearing it's like eroding ice
from underneath
and you don't notice it until you go
through and then when you go through
with tinnitus or
pitch shift you can't get it back
and in fact the number one problem with
hearing now isn't so much loud music
that's bad
if you do it over and over again that's
physically bad but headphones
one in six american children teenagers
has got damaged hearing as a result of
earbud headphones and playing music all
the time into their ears at 100 decibels
hours a day they're doing this hours a
day so effectively we may be raising a
whole deaf generation
so
sounds that you actually enjoy can be
just as harmful as sounds that you don't
enjoy absolutely don't like absolutely
and i mean really i would appeal to the
audience to anybody watching this if
they have children
really trying to educate children to
love their ears because they're damaging
them and i see terrible things like
children saying oh my ears will get used
to the noise no they don't what do you
what do you recommend this uh more
silence
silence is good but not all the time uh
i just are lowering a more conscious
creation of sound by organizations and
by individuals and a more conscious
listening if we all start listening what
about the voices inside my head
those i think you may need his mother to
sort out
her mother can help